hey guys pete here
we're gonna give this another shot we'll
be having an in-depth discussion about
the expanse season six episode four
with readout we are at the two thirds of
the way through the season point
and it's the final season and we have a
lot of interesting stuff to unpack here
there were some great character
exchanges that deserve a second look and
as far as the stream hopefully the third
time will be a charm
we're still new at this we're still
trying to improve each time we come back
and i think we can have a great
conversation today so
thanks for being here and supporting the
channel i'm joined again by
benja from the benja tv channel you want
to say hello
hi pete and hi guys in the chat
welcome once again and i'm excited to be
doing this again i can't believe we've
only got two episodes left
yeah it's really wild that it's just
getting going it feels like it's just
getting going but it's actually not it's
almost done you know
it's it's a sad situation but let's try
to make the best out of it
we're going to be talking all things
expanse
all the seasons of the show and the
books up to babylon's ashes
but we will be limiting spoilers we
won't be going past anything that
happened in this episode
so
let's jump into it we're gonna also do
the
x-ray episode the bonus episode with
clarissa mal that was called night watch
and i think we should i think we should
just start right there
yeah and
i think this is the fourth one we've got
uh clarissa has the has the watch while
everyone is asleep and she finds out
that her father julpiar mao has died
she's upset so she activates her mods
and trashes the kitchen
and now she records a heartbreaking
journal after waking up
which shows us that she feels she still
loves her father even though he was a
terrible man
and how do you feel about this one piece
how do you compare to the other extra
episodes
well i mean it had a hard job of
following up what will probably be the
best of these with amos and bobby
and it's a character that needs some
development in some in some ways you
know we know her as melba we're seeing
this transformation mostly in relation
to how she is next to amos how they
interact together
so i think it was a good addition
and i was i was kind of happy that they
gave an ending to jewel pierre mao
because he was so important
that never really happened in the books
um it was just sort of
he was put away in prison you kind of
figured he would die there but he was
never really mentioned so
this was a good way to give us something
with her and it's a complicated
situation as is any relationship with
any parent
so i thought it hit pretty well
what about um
i thought that
i thought it was really cool how they
use the cameras like there was some
creative stuff here that i thought would
work worked pretty well what did you
think about it in the overall terms of
how they put it together
yeah i think i liked it and
you know just kind of fits with this
whole family theme they've got going
uh you know naomi's dealing with philip
we've got the marco
phillips situation
in one of the previous episodes we saw
avasarala
listening to a message from her
grandparents
so they you know they've really
they really leaned on this stuff we also
got you know obviously
uh
drummer and hership their family so this
family drama
gets me going because you know this is
kind of favor
this is kind of my favorite genre family
dramas
and clarissa's
i guess monologue here her journal entry
was quite emotional and
like you said we didn't
get a lot of character development for
clarissa outside of her interactions
with amos so i thought this was good she
was
you know she was on her own
and her reaction felt really genuine so
i liked it
yeah i think that um another angle on it
is that whenever
whenever we see her by herself you get
that feeling of what it's like to live
in space too you know they're out there
not much to do
and that life still goes on you know
this is they're in the middle of a war
they've we've seen how stressed out
they've been through all of this and
then
this other thing that she has no control
of happens
and you know you were talking about how
the families you know how they're
emphasizing the family and i think that
makes sense because this is the found
family of the ross ante right this is
that this is basically how the show is
and the story is put together
and she's still on the outside of that
you know i mean she's still still
working her way in and we'll talk about
it a little bit later how she gets this
piece of information that
you know
that the captain the captain did
something and that puts her in a really
awkward spot too
yeah and and the other thing is this
idea of one ship right where you know
the the doctrine of one ship they've
kind of introduced all of these with
that
that's kind of like
people being you know like the cells of
an organism all working together you
know and
in this case she's still on the outside
but
she's becoming part of the family and at
the same time her other family her real
family is is coming to an end you know
so i thought that was kind of a neat
transition for someone to come into the
crew
yeah it gives her closure and uh we've
got a super chat here from tian martin
do you want to read this piece
okay
hi and happy new year is it cruel or
kind to show the laconia scenes and
bonus content
given that it's hurtling towards season
finale
yeah i i've always had to
you know kind of defer to you on this
because you haven't read the books you
don't know where that's going and i
guess we'll talk about that in a second
for for a book reader it is
great to see this because
you know one i think it's a good story i
think it does add to what's going on
even though it's a little disconnected
but
you know this is something we might not
we might not otherwise see if there
aren't if if they never do the last
three books
but i got we've talked about it in the
past it's kind of it's kind of
bittersweet at the same time though
because it is setting up
something that we're not guaranteed to
see
so i'll just defer to you one last time
on that if you want to add anything
yeah i do think it's cruel
definitely because they're teasing
something that they might not be able to
deliver
and
but but at the same time you could view
this as you know as a little wink to us
viewers that they do plan to
follow up on this
pull off on this teas
so you know you could look at it that
way as well but i think for now it's
cruel
because um
my hopes are in high that this will uh
continue
it's a little bit of both like most
things in life isn't it
exactly
well thanks for the super chat
and get into i think we could probably
transition right into laconia from there
huh yep exactly uh we meet admiral mr
duarte in laconia he's the leader of the
breakaway martian fleet and he pays his
respects to kara's family because her
brother zan has passed away
we talked about this last week
and when duarte talks about dealing with
creep
grief
kara wants to learn if he has lost a
child but he says he has lost a place
meaning mars or the dream of mars so
what did you take away from duarte's
speech and what do you think about his
introduction yeah i mean this was big
for for book readers like you know in
the reddit in the subreddit for the last
few years people have been
talking about who might be cast and
you know it's a big deal absolutely and
uh
i thought the i thought the actor is not
someone i had heard of before but i
thought he did a pretty pretty excellent
job really of capturing because this guy
is both kind of creepy and charismatic
at the science at the same time isn't he
exactly i mean
he the way the way he speaks to kara
there
you know
who gives who gives a speech like that
to
to a kid like that i don't really i
don't really get that
no yeah she's an eight-year-old she's an
eight-year-old and i mean
yeah and she he's speaking like he's
giving a philosophy lecture or something
that was that was interesting you know
it definitely that tells us something
about tortoise character
yeah and i thought the background i
think if you listen you know when you if
you turn up the volume and kind of pay
attention to how they're
eavesdropping on the cam on what the
people are saying there you know what i
mean
i thought that was a nice touch because
these people are there with him they
followed him there
the ones that are in his group
and they are they're talking about how
this guy you know he wrecked the the
cart it it killed this kid
and you know this is going to be
something that
they think is he's going to be executed
for did you pick up on that
actually didn't hear that until i
watched your breakdown which is
one of the reasons i do
and you know that was a good spot
because
um
i didn't hear that and i i was kind of
surprised because
we did see
i think that same guy almost running
over cara earlier in the season
so maybe it might be the same guy
yeah we i don't know if they confirmed
it's the same driver but it's the same
situation for sure
yeah
we've got a great comment here because
justin merritt says aidan gillen the
actor playing littlefinger would have
been perfect
what do you think about that
i i think that he would be perfect in a
lot of things yeah he i think the
i think the fan cast for this because
they kind of does you know his name's
duarte and they kind of
he's kind of a short and unassuming guy
in the books from what i remember and
one of his his um
one of his
the characteristics that they they note
is that he has the pockmark face
so
there was a lot of talk of like edward
james almost playing this role and
things like that
yeah but yeah aidan gillan that would
have been a good one
and i think we can continue because um
we see cortisol again the prior molecule
scientist he interrupts their
conversation cara andrade's conversation
to tell duarte that
his new coordination protocol returned a
coherent reply pattern whatever that
means we'll get into that
and cortazar believes he can turn it on
the camera cuts to the orbital platform
suggesting that the quote-unquote hit
quarter
might have been something to do with
what he's talking about
so
um
this part was really mysterious
uh what did you what do you think
they're planning i think you kind of
know but
yeah i know so i i can't say but i just
want to point out that i love how
cortazar is so
focused so single-mindedly focused so
he's coming into awake people are upset
and sad and he can't contain himself
like he is
he's got a proto-molecule boner you know
what i mean like
it's it's it's perfect like i really
love this character the idea that you
know he was altered so that he's
basically a sociopath
and
this i i loved his entrance here and
you know you you brought it up that they
showed the orbital platform i don't
think that that's really subtle they're
trying to say that this is the thing
that he's trying to communicate with
what do you think that might mean like
if we just take that as
what they're showing us what do you
think that might mean as a non-book
reader
you know my
i guess my generic response would be
it's it's an overpowered ship that's got
a product molecule um
molecule technology
so
and that would be my response that
that's what i think at the moment
i haven't got much to go on
so i don't know
yeah i mean
it doesn't know i mean look at that
thing
yeah the the test the test case i think
the thing that you could
keep in mind is the test case was illus
you know that that
that conversation with babbage and
alex last season when she was really
trying to prick i mean really trying to
pick his brain about what happened when
they brought the proto-molecule to illus
they're trying to recreate that
situation here
and if you remember it didn't actually
go very well whenever they turned it on
and
um
but because
because because cortisol is involved in
this situation and they seem to have
been doing this for a long time i think
this one might go well
and that's that's their
that's certainly their hope
oh
and then yeah things might uh
turn sour
[Music]
well i mean you know i'm not i'm not
saying either way i'm just saying that
that's why they did what they did that's
why they brought cortisar with them is
that outside of holden this guy has the
most experience with
studying the proto molecule
and so you know i mean that that's
that's the whole reason that that he's
there
all right i think
we can talk about care now because
as anticipated she takes her brother's
body into the forest
now that trying to fix him using the
strange dogs there's no subtlety here
really because they've set this up
really well
i'm just i'm still thinking if he's
gonna he's gonna turn into a hybrid
because uh we talked about this last
weekend
i think it's pretty clear that um
these strange dogs don't just uh revive
things
suddenly but
you know they do but uh they changed
them as well they
they add a different element to them
maybe that element is the prime molecule
i don't know but
uh you know and you know where this is
heading so i want to pick your brain on
this
well i i just wanted to look at it this
way the the one of the things that i
loved about this book when i first read
it this this novella it's really short
you can anyone can read this in a couple
of hours maybe you know
i don't know how many i can't remember
how many words it is but it's it's it's
a very short
complete story
in a lot of ways but um
the thing i love about it is it's from
an eight-year-old girl's perspective you
know she's the one that's experiencing
these things if her parents or cortazar
or someone else
had seen this bird brought back
they would think okay well that is
creepy that's something that we need to
study and be careful with because we
wouldn't want that to happen
inadvertently you know
she's a little kid and she's just
looking at it like hey you know what i
got a problem i got this brother he's
dead and
a couple of days ago i had a problem
with my
my drone was broken
and and then the mother bird died
because i accidentally fed her some food
from earth and yeah you know this might
work
so it's kind of that situation and you
know people point out that
why is she running around in the woods
on the on this planet by herself and
how can she just roll this body out here
you know like you're gonna have to give
it a little bit i guess but
that's also sort of the point you know
if someone who was a full-grown
adult with a you know
with any kind of sense experienced this
it would have all gone very differently
and
you know i i like that i like the idea
here that
it's crazy what she's doing
you know
especially
yeah you should not you should not do
this this is ill-advised
to mess with things like that that you
don't understand but it's a perfect
comparison of what
duarte and cortizar are trying to do
with the proto-molecule in general
and jewel pierre mao before them you
know what i mean
in a lot of ways humanity is sort of
worse than
little kids when it comes to the
proto-molecule
they just can't help themselves
agreed and we've got a question from
disco 70
i'm only optimist book four would it
ruin the story if i read stranger
strange dogs now
um
not necessarily
i mean if you've watched the show this
far then then i would say no
you know what i mean because you already
know that
you already basically know what's what
happens in book five from the tv show
so yeah if if
if you're only reading and and it
wouldn't make sense that you're here
watching this stream if if you you were
doing that
i would say it's yeah it wouldn't really
spoil anything major there that you
haven't already seen the tv show
yeah and um
i just wanted to say that
this kerosene i thought
would have come earlier in the episode
and we would we would maybe see the end
result of what happens to zan
so uh
dwight is in duarte's intro introduction
delayed this for a little bit and
this i think this
this is going to go until the end of the
season and we will see what happens
happens to zan at the end of the season
so maybe i thought we'd see this this
episode or the next one but
looks like that's going to take a while
yeah they're they're definitely
there's definitely one of these in both
of the upcoming episodes that starts off
this the thing and i i won't really say
anything more about that but
it gets somewhere
all right do you have anything to add on
this or should we move to series
um i i think maybe we can come back and
talk a little bit more about duarte at
the very end i don't want to derail i do
want to talk about
that situation a little bit more but i
think it makes sense if we come back to
that or if anybody has any specific
questions because we got a lot of stuff
in the main episode that we still have
to look at
okay and
i think it's time to talk about series
now
because the belters are still making a
stand there against the inners where
dozens of um marines and martians died
after last week's attack okay kernel
would like to up and leave she wants to
turn their attention towards ring to
take back medina
but also allah does not believe they
would be able to do that
they don't have enough firepower she
thinks
nonetheless we see that the martians
will attempt this takeover on their own
so what do we think about this uh
disagreement who do you side with here
i
i mean it's hard to say if if one is is
right or wrong
they're two different approaches
i think what's interesting is that
carino
got that message from mcr command mcrn
command and that
they're willing to do that on their own
it kind of it kind of underlines the
idea that
these are two different factions they're
working together but they don't have
they're not exactly like-minded in their
attention you know what they're thinking
about
and i just wanted to mention the
sandrani
thing in the beginning because when i
first saw this i was kind of like
why
i don't i couldn't kind of get where she
was coming from
and what did you think about the fact
that
they were just attacked by the free navy
but here she is in in the public square
talking about
don't side with the inners
i you know i found this realistic
because
this is the belter mindset rightly they
don't trust the inners and
just because marco
i suppose um betrayed them does not mean
they should just uh side with their
enemy there
i mean
i think that's that's what i was that's
what i was getting at because we can see
in episode five that whether it's
upcoming
you know i was making the uh teaser
video yesterday and we kind of see that
that is drummer's
situation
that she's going to be facing
so yeah i thought this was a pretty a
pretty interesting little scene that's
just sort of in there where you're
thinking well that's crazy how can you
not
you know this guy just
is behind he's behind the explosions you
would imagine that's what they said when
they were talking you know their belter
made charges so
it's kind of wild that you know even
though you you you see everything that's
going on it's still kind of hard to
understand
just what a tough situation that is for
them you know looking
looking at this from their perspective i
mean what happens if they just defeat
the free navy and kill marco
and deaners take control they go back to
square one maybe even worse because
there's you know
there's a um catastrophic situation on
earth supplies are running low
uh food is hard to come by so what's
going to happen to the belt if
if thinners regain control
they have to the belters have to think
for themselves
so yeah i think sandrana's
points
make sense
yeah and and like
you know we're talking about carino
a little bit of a character flip for her
because she was the one that was in back
in season three when she was there the
first time she was the one that was kind
of like level headed and didn't jump in
to the battle that was going on there
when she had a clear advantage to kind
of
capitalize in that situation
so it's an interesting twist in that
character's development and
you know i i don't think that you could
say that either one is
i don't think you could say who's who's
right or wrong there or if even anyone
is but
you kind of see both of them like the
points that they're making
we had a couple of super chats here i
just wanted to
before we move on there it says sean
doyle landed a top a top role on star
trek discovery
seems like they are
co-opting concepts from the expansion
actors
i i'm this isn't a show that i'm
familiar with have you watched this
uh unfortunately i i've seen a few
episodes but
i wouldn't recommend it but uh i think
sean doyle is aaron right right
yes
oh yeah
uh yeah and he he's a great actor he's a
canadian actor obviously a lot of these
people they shoot in toronto so a lot of
these
uh actors come from that area and
i don't think i really appreciated his
performance the first time i watched the
show but every time i re-watch i always
pick up on he does a great job in that
role i mean he's a not a likeable
character in any way really but yeah but
he's the reason he's the reason fine
character yeah he's the reason why um
we like also so much because
she had to overcome a person like aaron
right
as far as i remember
yes
i think that
it's good i think he should be in more
shows that's what i would say about the
super chat you know i mean i think that
he would he he would add to any cast
from what i've seen in his work in the
expanse
we've got another super chat but i'm not
sure if you want to read that because
youtube doesn't like
australia yeah i'm a little bit
i am a little bit um
apprehensive about doing that
but alex tyler
yeah i appreciate
the five dollars but
i'm not even sure that could be bait to
get that you know a misinformation kind
of thing going on
yeah
it's like playing a song that you don't
have the the rights to
exactly don't do that
i think we can move on to the risi now
it's still on its way to series there's
an alex tribute here because they're
playing his song i think bobby is
and also clarissa finds out that it was
holden who disarmed the torpedo that was
about to destroy the pela
she shares this information with amos
who says he will handle it
we will dive deeper into this later on
but i just want to ask you how you react
to this bit about alex and also what did
you think about clarissa keeping this on
the wraps and only sharing it with amos
well i think the the song the tribute to
the to alex i think it's an ongoing
reminder that they're doing a pretty job
a pretty good job with a
kind of terrible situation that they
found themselves in uh it's a nice call
back to that i don't remember the name
of the or which episode it was but
the old episode where he's in the in the
ship when they're on i think they're on
io or ganymede and he's just waiting for
them
and he's uh he he has the music cranked
up and he does like he's like doing
tricks in the zero g do you do you
remember what i'm talking about yeah
yeah i think people have done some
montages with that
yeah so it it was it's another another
instance where they're you know giving
us final sea final season vibes you know
what i mean calling pulling on strings
from the from the uh previous seasons in
a way that
they always kind of do that you know
there's always a lot of foreshadowing
and reconnecting callbacks and things
like that but
i think these ones have a very specific
final season kind of feel to them
and i thought this one was great and
it's nice that they're able to that
they're like the the biggest thing when
you hear six episodes is you're thinking
okay this is gonna be so rust they're
gonna just ignore the character stuff
it's gonna be all hitting the plot
points and
rushing to the end
and i think this is something that's
great to see that they still take time
to do something like that
man yeah this season this season is full
of um
loving full of interesting character
developments and they do a good job of
um
i guess uh
developing some relationships as well
because
they give naomi and holding a lot of
time
we've got um avasarala and monica you
know their little arrangement is
interesting
there's there's there uh marco and
rosenfeld
i'm not saying relationships in uh
in a romantic sense but you know what i
mean
they're giving this a lot of
they're giving this stuff a lot of uh
air time
yeah i think that um
you know like i said the biggest fear
that you you worry about like if you
think about the classic example that
everybody compares everything to right
now in this time and it's the game of
thrones ending oh my god
you know that was a trend that happened
why would you bring that up piece
well you know it's
just i'm just trying to make a
comparison because i still see comments
every video of the experience i put out
i still see comments where people are
comparing those two things
and i just think that you know the the
thing there was is that they they
started jumping from set piece to set
piece you know they just were hitting
the points on the way to the end
and i feel like this this kind of scene
right here is a great example of how
the expanse is not doing that
and yeah i don't think that so far
anyways we haven't seen like really
strange leaps forward in the plot in the
structure of the way the episodes are
set up
that you know that it's losing something
on either end
now for example you know clarissa isn't
just suddenly
one of the one of the guys one of the
girls
she has to be developed and they're
giving her time it's been four episodes
and
she's just now
um
getting it together with holden so
they're really
they're really patient with this
character stuff
yeah i think it's i think it's you know
it's great and i'm happy that
you know i'm not happy that it's coming
to an end but
i'm happy that they're at least
putting that kind of attention to these
people because that's what the story's
about
so we have a
super chat here it says
to me sandrani's outrage and distrust
doesn't feel earned in the scene and
doesn't fit the character
well i i kind of get what you're saying
there and that i think that
sandrani and rosenfeld are two
points in this final season that are
it's it's tough because we never heard
of these people before
and now they have to carry a lot in that
they're
they're belters that are connected to
the free navy
because obviously you know we need those
people they're in charge and
i don't know if it
i guess yeah i mean i i guess i can see
your point it's your experience
i thought that
saying i thought sandrani i thought
there when i first watched the season i
thought that there would be a syndrome i
thought one of the um
my guess was that one of the x-ray
episodes would have been with sandrani
to give us a little bit more about
you know how she became
how they became you know
in that position or how they
develop that
point of view but
i think that it on the second time
through it you know it worked a little
bit better but
that's where they didn't really have
time to
develop all the new characters it's sort
of like the guy who walks around with
abisarala too i think his name is gareth
he just yeah he just kind of
you know he's just there all of a sudden
you know he would have been
the guy delgado last season if you look
at those two characters delgado was a
lot it was definitely a lot more
of a character that you felt like you
knew by the end of the season gareth is
just sort of
there right
now this is where 10 episodes would have
been ideal
because they would have given them what
three more hours to develop these
characters
oh yeah yeah i i i had i you know
there's
there's legitimate
issues with certain things as far as
covid and
the way that affected some of the ways
what i thought affected some of the
characters that they might have brought
back or didn't bring back and
yeah i think the free navy
side characters are a little
a little underdeveloped from what i
would like to see but if the trade-off
is that we get more
drummer and we get more of the core crew
i mean which which would you rather
i mean that's an easy decision to be
right it's not really it's almost
rhetorical in that sense isn't it
exactly yeah i wanted to answer jeff
fielder's question here before we move
on to the pella
he asks who has played the expanse
computer game what is it like uh it
hasn't come out yet it's gonna it's
gonna be a couple of years before it
does but i'm gonna touch on this game
more when we get to um the supply depot
scene with uh drummer
so i think now we we can move on to the
pella
marco wants the two most senior members
of the lobber crew spaced because they
failed the medal against the rossi
and while philip has been reassigned to
be a repair technician
this was a this was a surprise
and rosenfeld feels like marco is a
little bit rattled and that he needs
philip by his side
to to remain calm so she has a word with
philip to convince him to
apologize to marco even though she
accepts phil was right
and philip remains stubborn and philip
remains stubborn and goes on with his
repair job
so what did you think about
marco's decision here it's it did seem
way too harsh for me
so
i want to hear what you think about this
yeah the way i took the way i interpret
it was that he did this thing it was
obviously an unforced error and now he
wants to shift the blame to someone else
and
you know that's a pretty dramatic way to
do that
i think it's ill-advised obviously you
only have so many people that you can
count on that you can trust to hear i
don't i mean i'm not a military
tactician i've never been in a spaceship
but
i don't think that
what they did
they did you know they were hit by the
railgun shot the first time that the uh
you know they flipped around and did it
and
i don't know it seems like they
they're kind of carrying carrying the
the weight of
marco making a
an emotional decision to go after the
ross and nantes when they didn't even
need to be there
um yeah and i think we can touch more on
philip by mentioning tadeo
uh the repair technician phillips
working with and they got on with their
work and i really enjoyed this sequence
because it gave us a look at the daily
life of you know a crew member on board
a spaceship and tadeo's personal story
was interesting as well because he
talked about how his
brother saved him from becoming a
failure
and this made philip realize how
different his situation would have been
if he wasn't marco's son
and uh tadeo's brother
suspects that his brother died at um
died on series when
the explosions happened so
that's why his personal story is
interesting
and what did you make
what did you make of these two guys
yeah there's a ton of stuff in this
little this little conversation that
they have and it's funny because
this is one of those
scenes where they have this like video
game kind of thing where he's
putting the you know there's like this
really technical part of the scene that
that is kind of completely unnecessary
in a lot of ways you know what i mean i
think this is just the expense showing
off
that's the one i i when i did uh when i
did the review i said i think there
there's the one scene that it just seems
like okay you guys are just showing off
here with this you know what i mean and
this is what it was because there these
two are like
just in the uh just recently phillips
father told him that the people on on
series are all basically soft they're
weak that you know they only are there
living high on the hog because you know
they're they're
following earth and you know doing their
bidding or whatever
and it was a you know
here he's talking about his brother who
is dedicated to the to the cause but
he just can't go into space you know i
mean he has this condition where he
experiences um vertigo
so you have that
philip says oh so i guess not everyone
you know he thinks in his head you know
not everyone on series is
like different
in that way or whatever and then you
have
philip is a child soldier right
that's the only life he
he's known
and you see him here he's interacting
with somebody just a regular person he's
doing a regular job and you see that he
has that feeling of accomplishment as
he's you know flying this drone around
or
whatever it is and
it's kind of like you know
it's kind of sad that he he's getting a
taste of that but you know that he's not
really ever going to be free of his
you know this lifestyle that he was born
into
yeah and this is
i think this is going to have a tragic
ending for philip because
i will also talk about what naomi thinks
of uh
philip later on but
it it it kind of feels like to me that
philip's story is basically a tragedy
and as you know tragedies end with
a death
and
this is where
his story is his story is heading
yeah and i do i like these little
looks into
belter life like they did that really
well i think with the news feeds a
couple episodes back
this gives us a look inside and then
we'll talk about it in a little bit but
the uh lucky earther cat guy later you
know
there's a lot of
there's a lot of uh hum there's a lot of
human stories mixed in with all of
what's happening and you know it's uh
it's another part where
it's nice to be able to
get a little bit of a glimpse of that
as a you know as a counter to the actual
fighting that's going on
okay i think uh we can move on to the
rossi if you have if you haven't got
anything to add well we should say that
they recovered the warhead as well
yeah i forgot to mention that that's
kind of important the way that they are
messed with philippe was absolutely
hilarious because i thought he was
serious at first too
absolutely if there's a nuclear missile
right there
you're gonna think he's here i mean i
believed that philip thought he was
serious of nothing else right
exactly
do you um
did what did you think about them
recovering this did this seem just like
normal everyday
work on a ship or do you think there's
some bigger significance because i had a
ton of
comments that i read where people
were theorizing that this this nuclear
uh warhead was going to be important
later
um i think they they say that they
they're just going to use this
later on because it's not damaged
it's not damaged it was discerned
so maybe this is going to be used to
kill an important person in this story
but i don't think so i don't think
that's where this is ending i think
they're just going to leave this behind
maybe it will impact you know philip
because he he later learns in the
episode that
it was disarmed by holden but maybe this
warhead will impact um
his decisions going forward philip's
decisions but
the missile
the missile itself i don't think is
going to play an important role that's
the feeling i have
okay yeah and like you said we'll come
back around to that whenever we talk
about the the last scene where he gives
his little uh
he tries to call on the uh
uh raise the morale of the troops or
whatever
yeah
and at the rossi on the russia aims and
all the never chat as they work on the
pdc
and amos can't figure out how
what holden did was the right thing to
do in that situation because he expects
amos
expect that amos expects paulden to do
the right thing um nothing is
resolved here because holding cannot
just justify his decision that easily
so i wanted to ask what you thought
about this confrontation
well yeah i i love this this is the one
of the first and you know the first time
i watched it this was one of my favorite
um
amos
holden interactions maybe in you know
most like there's a lot of good ones
over the years obviously but
out of the recent ones this one it's
they set it up a little bit in episode
one where he tells him that
you know he follows him he he's out
there because
you know he wants them not to think
about the thing that's going on at the
rings with the ships because they don't
have to worry about that you know he's
out there to back him up because
he he believes in him
and he doesn't want that you know he
doesn't want anything to happen
and this is like
from his point of view this is a huge
betrayal right
i mean
he is
can you think about it
can you think of you know how would how
he would react if this was i don't know
in season two
or maybe even in season one
right and we did actually see him react
to being betrayed in the same way with
naomi you know naomi like the thing
about amos is he he he doesn't trust his
moral compass he doesn't trust his
ability to make the right decisions
so he picks these people
he puts them on a pedestal and he says
that i'm gonna try to do what i think
naomi would do in this situation you
know
i'm gonna be completely loyal and back
them up and then whenever i have to make
a decision i'm gonna try to do what i
think that she would do that's where he
was whenever he
came in as a crew member of the ross
ante
in time he came to do the same thing
with holden
so right here that's the cognitive
dissonance that he's dealing with right
he's saying
i expect that
maybe to a fault in some points that
you're always going to do what the right
what you think is the right thing and
what's best for everybody
and now i can't put the i can't
i can't make this
i can't put it together in my head i
can't make this work
and it's fantastic because
holden can't either
it was an emotional decision he did
something it was selfish
as far as the big picture as far as
ending the war it was a thing that was
only
he's only thinking about himself and
about his relationship
about someone he cares about and we'll
come back to that but
yeah i really liked it and i liked how
he kind of gave
he kind of gave his friend you know his
his captain yes but also his friend
a possible way out you know he said i
could just turn i could just take you
out of fire control
yeah so i'll just i'll just i'll just do
it for you you won't have to make a
decision
it'll already be done
yeah i i don't know what did you think
about
i had i had some people mention in the
comments that they thought it was wild
that
he told that holden told him that he
didn't
um he didn't
owe him an explanation what did you
think about that part of it
i think
and nor and
i think holden normally wouldn't do that
but
as we said you know they've been out
here
for
uh what six months now more than six
months
and
we've noticed that he doesn't look
really he doesn't look that good now
both physically and mentally
so maybe this is his way of
uh lashing out i suppose because
normally he could have explained the
situation to amos and i think amos would
have understood
he'd still
want
he still wants pete
he'd still want holden to go through
with killing marco but i think amish
would have understood if holding just to
explain his situation but because he's
been out here he's not in the right
mindset meaning holden
so i think that's why
he said he doesn't
need to justify his actions
i'm the captain now he and this that's
kind of what he said
yeah you kind of think about how you
kind of think about how drummer with her
crew you know is it like are you my wife
right now or are you my captain
i kind of took it as him just being like
look i'm the captain of this ship when i
you know when i make a decision
right or wrong it's the decision and
you know there's he knew he couldn't
justify it
amos pulled him out
he pulled him up on that a second later
saying are you mad because i brought it
up or are you mad because you know you
don't have an explanation
so i i just thought it was you know a
really great back and forth and it's
it's and it's a situation where there
isn't really
any resolution there can't be
you know he did what he did
he can't make that make sense for amos
because it doesn't
exactly and
they discussed this further with naomi
as holden goes back to his quarters
she's not happy about this either either
when she learns about this
because she has already tried to save
her family and phillip but it hasn't
worked out she has chosen
his new she has chosen her new family
meaning the rossi
as she has made her peace with the fact
that philip might die if the free navy
loses the war so she had already made
her decision
and she doesn't want holden to spare
phillip just to spare her feelings
i thought this was
one of the better scenes of the episode
because
naomi was absolutely right to point that
out
holden kind of made her responsible for
what marco might do next
so i was completely with naomi on this
one
who do you side with here
yeah i mean
it's another one where you can't really
you can't
you can't sigh you can't side with
holden here like objectively like you
know it's a bad choice it's it's
even if you take everything out of it i
mean he just
you can't justify what he did under any
other reason except for that
he didn't want to
see naomi go through that
and you know she's absolutely correct in
saying that you don't get to decide that
you know she's there she she
she went and she tried to save her son
that didn't work out
and now
through his decisions and trying to
protect her or whatever you you know
whatever his justification is
he's making her complicit
in whatever happens after the fact
and that's pretty messed up you know
what i mean that's not
she's going through enough does she
really need to be responsible for the
fact that the free navy say the free
navy goes and
has a
mass casualty event where you know
thousands of people tens of thousands of
people die
that's kind of on their hands at this
point
absolutely i mean not on their hands i
think holden
yeah but i mean he hurt but he said but
but in saying that he did it because of
her oh yeah because of not wanting to be
the person to kill her son yeah i was i
was talking from an objective standpoint
naomi will feel the way you describe it
but from an objective standpoint it's
just olden's fault but i agree with you
that
and naomi will feel that
way yeah and i like that they put the i
like that they they created this
situation
and
uh you got to say holden is having a day
here isn't he yeah the last two
conversations he had
and i mean and he deserves it it's all
because of the choices he made it's not
like he's being you know called out
unjustifiably or whatever but it's like
i like that they made these kinds of
human situations where you can't really
like
you can't you can't get behind what he
did
but you understand why he did it
does that make sense
yeah you know the reason why but yeah
but you don't agree with it i i get it
yeah like you you know you you can
based on
the the choices if you look at it and
you say okay this is gonna happen or
that's gonna happen
you can't do what he did
but as a viewer as someone that's
engaging with the story you can 100
understand
why he did it when he explains it
from his
perspective yeah we've got another super
chat by the way
holden still has the codes to this is
from sam jovi thank you for the five
dollars it holden still has the codes
to the nuke now on the
on the pella
i think that could turn the deactivation
in episode three to an assist if he
triggers it later
i don't think that's possible
yeah i saw this i saw this um a lot of
different people thought this it
i
they i mean they're on a martian ship
i would think if they can take control
of of it and repurpose it then they
would have
control over the codes at that point but
yeah the pillar i mean it's kind of like
it's kind of like
you know
not really i i'm kind of just putting
that together in my head because it
seems like
you know that that's not i don't think
it was intentional i think that we see
that emotionally why he did that he you
know he explains that so
is it possible i mean it might be
technically possible but i don't think
that's where they're going with it yeah
and if you know if the technicians that
depend on the pella you know reprogram
the missile it should be impossible
and i think they would
yeah i think i like i said we're we're
just making up stuff about yeah it's
just not a real thing anyway so
it's not scientific this isn't backed
with science at all
just speculation
uh i think we can speculate about
clarissa's um
diet choices now because
her salt obsession is quite the thing
uh we we see her and holden have a
conversation where she tells holden to
never feel bad for not killing somebody
and this kind of
this is uh different from holden's other
interactions because clarissa is quite
supportive because
she
she had a cause and killed people
because of that
and that has damaged her forever so she
understands why holden couldn't go
through with that
couldn't go through with killing philip
and the connection these two share
clarissa and holden continues to grow
stronger each week
i wasn't sure how she would fit in but
it's fair to say she has exceeded my
expectations so far and this was another
great example of that
how did you feel about this particular
conversation
yeah it was great it i don't know it
would be hard to rank these different
conversations because he has three three
epic
showdowns with the different cat you
know different crew members
i think that it's you know and the
the history that they have together
and the way that they open this up you
know she says
do you want to know the time when i
decided i wasn't going to kill you
and this is something that
i saw not that long ago whenever i was
uh working on the drummer video that
scene
that's that's a call back to something
that actually happens on screen
you see her make that decision on the um
on the behemoth as the you know as
everything's coming to an end in season
three
so you know their history it makes it it
kind of absurd in a way that
he would even be in the same room
listening to her
or that she would have the right thing
to say at
this really
stressful juncture in his you know in
his uh
his time as as the captain of ross ante
i think that
you know it's i don't think that you
know what she says is is i think what
she
what she says is really useful for where
he's at at the moment right
he's
he you know he it's the it's it's the
thing he needed to hear
although you know i don't think it's
really an endorsement on
the way he what he did either does that
make sense
yeah
you need i think
i think there is a notice you need
friends like that too because
they can't just all bash holden
so he's just trying to yeah she's just
trying to boost his morale
i get why i get why she's doing it
and and she's out of everyone on the
crew she's she has
her regrets are for front and center you
know she's trying to atone herself
her previous actions and so he knows the
place it's coming from even though he's
not really
he's not really as opposed to her as a
person
in the tv show as he is in the book
he's really he's really not comfortable
with her being there for a long time in
the books but
still they have that history so it makes
it it gives it a different
it gives it a different um
it's not the same as if someone else
said it so
i thought that this was great and i
really liked how she was
dumping the uh salt on her food at the
end and he's just kind of looking at her
like
seriously
and i think i think that
you know i think when this series
started
i wasn't sure about
steven straight as as an actor
i thought you know he
i thought he filled the role that what
he was being given but
i think when i watched this episode i
got a different appreciation for
his you know i think he's a lot better
than he he used to be i think i think
he's doing things that maybe they didn't
even ask him to do before and he's been
up to the challenge i think it's what do
you think about
how how these two interact as actors
huh
and you know i can't really
i think almost every single actor on
this show has gotten better over the
course of these seasons
because um
so i'm not sure if that's really um
that's really if that only goes for
steven strait
because when they started out they none
of them were that famous
so i think most of the main characters
at least um has gotten have gotten
better
yeah but
their interactions overall karissa and
uh hold on i think i i like them
i think they're the best thing on uh
they're one of the best things on the
rossi this season
yeah it's a little bit lighter that i
think that benefits things too because
even though she tried to kill him and
she can talk about that and he can
listen about that
it's still a little bit lighter because
they're still getting to know each other
whereas with amos there's a lot of
history with naomi there's a lot of
history and there's stakes in that
because they're a you know they're a
couple
so it's a nice it's a nice uh it's a
nice addition to the dynamics there and
we have a
we have a super chat
another five dollars from tm martin
thank you for that
what are your top three ships on the
expanse
season one through six
do you want to stab at that
i just wanted to say that
uh
i know how much you like ranking things
so this question is
just yeah i wanted to say medina station
is my favorite
i'm not sure if we're calling that a
ship but
well it was it was a generation ship
first it was the naboo
yeah
that's my favorite but i don't know
i don't i don't know how to rank the
others i guess the rossi has to be there
in my top three
uh yeah
i can't decide on the other one
i think as far as
i think as far as
just
cool looking technology i think that the
stealth ships and the in the
the uh
i'm trying to think of the class it was
a it's a egyptian class um
i can't think about it but yeah the
anubis was
was a cool looking ship especially in
the early seasons and i always thought
that the doninger class was
the coolest looking
as far as the way it looks on this on
the screen
as far as the uh as the big ships
the rossi yeah it has the it has the
sentimental factor how could you not put
that on the list but
the pellet looks pretty cool as well so
all of them are i mean it's yeah yeah
she said i'm not i'm not big on random
things but i think that you have to give
the anubis sort of like the
exotic
the the exotic um
you know the design is is definitely
of its of itself you know what i mean
it's different than everything else and
then
i just think the donager class look like
a city floating around in space with a
lot of
you know it's just
completely death machine at the same
time you know what i mean i think that's
really cool and then
we'll give the rossi the the final spot
on that
they definitely got the coolest looking
ship on
in television or movie history i think
yeah not even close
yeah they they did they were smart in
making it you know functional rather
than
just cool looking you know
exactly and functionally can be cool too
i mean that's the thing
absolutely
i think we can move on to drummer and
her crew
this is what i think is the best
sequence of the week
they have arrived at the spun up supply
depots and the way they all line up here
before they go in
with an incredible piece of soundtrack
playing in the background
made this a bonafide expanse moment even
before all the action
just just you know when they were just
stan not standing floating in space yeah
uh it was awesome did you get the same
amount of
goosebumps i got here peace
yeah when the scene first started
yeah this was one that i i didn't really
know how to visualize it until i saw you
know until i saw what it was
like the whole idea of the supply depot
and and the shipping like made out of
the shipping containers kind of thing
and
like you said the opening part where
it's sort of like you know it's sort of
like a a heist movie or something where
they show up at the location you know
the band of people that are gonna gonna
break in and they're looking at it from
a hillside on the distance or whatever
only instead here we have uh you know we
have them floating in their and their
vac suits looking on and
there was i thought that was i loved how
they they shot that in the beginning and
then
one of my favorite parts of this was
you're looking at you you have a shot of
kamina and you see her face plate
and the first time you see the the
structure you see it reflected in her
face plate going by you know you see it
moving by and that
and you're sort of like you know it's
colorful because they're all different
containers that are of different colors
so
there's this thing that appears on her
face plate and then you get the idea of
what's going on so i thought that was
super cool
next they make their way to the depot
but there are guards protecting the
containers and they ambush drummer and
company
and joseph is pinned under a crate as as
a cause his arm is crushed and they
can't move the crate because he would
bleed out they need a medic so they they
need michio
she arrives to resolve the problem but
joseph's arm is crushed once again after
they pry the crate up to apply a
tourniquet
and
because of this mitchell has to amputate
his arm to save him
now i definitely wasn't expecting this
much gore
but
i i was i was glad to see it i know i
don't know if that's the right way to um
my way to
express myself but
this scene really made me happy for some
reason and i'm not i'm not i'm not big
on gore
but seeing this here
it was just awesome what did you think
about this action sequence
yeah it was a great setup i the whole
idea of them going inside and
the shootout
that was pretty basic you know that
wasn't it was fine it it it served its
purpose but
the whole thing went to a different
level whenever
he gets pinned underneath this this
crate and
you know it's a couple of things at the
same time it's it's showing us the
reality of how crazy it is to be in
space and how quickly things can go
wrong and
you're gonna die if that happens right
and then we also have michio was earlier
in the season they were going to throw
her off the ship because they you know
they didn't have a
she wasn't ready for the battle that's
what they were thinking
so now she can use her her skills to
come in and save the day and it's all a
part of this idea of the one ship the
family
everybody has a role to play and
as you said
i was not expecting it to get like what
it got like
when he's stuck i'm thinking oh yeah
okay okay makes sense makes sense you
can't move the you can't move the crate
because he'll bleed out you know the
pressure is keeping the blood inside of
his body so you know you have to time
off tie off a tourniquet
i didn't think that they were going to
cut his arm off until
they cut his arm off you know whenever
she said to him
i love you i'm sorry
i mean it was a great it was great and
then walker walker i didn't catch it the
first time i i i watched it but
what does he say he says
tough work or
i i didn't i don't think i put it in the
notes but he calls her cargo because he
was
he was
brought into the story because he was
going to transpo transport her away
so that was just like i said that guy he
just makes his lines count doesn't he
every single one oh yeah i do you
remember the one about
the revolution
about an evolution worth having
yeah
if you don't get rich what's the point
right
exactly
that was a that was an awesome thing
he doesn't like you said he doesn't
speak a lot
yeah yeah he doesn't speak a lot but
he makes them comes
yeah they all they all hit
he just comes in and when they need to
deliver something he just comes in and
does it
i also like to you know how
michio wasn't really
scared of violence but
because you know she's a medic
so she
she can do this because uh she's saving
somebody's life
but when she has to you know destroy a
ship
i mean they're going i think that was in
episode one
when michio
just froze couldn't do it couldn't go
through with it
you know destroying a life and saving a
life
is two different things and she was
ready to
show us that gore let's just say
to save joseph's life
so yeah they need they need mitchell as
well i think this
underlines
that fact
which might not be
ideal for them in a um you know
one-on-one situation when they're
fighting another ship but
they're gonna need a medic like her
who's who's willing to do what's
necessary so michio in this episode was
great as well
yeah i think she did like you said i
would agree with everything that you
said there and i think it does
it's another one of those things that
you can draw parallels to what's
happening in this little family here and
the way that they're understanding that
to the bigger picture as well because
marco is in a position where
he's not going to
he's not going to give up his the the
bit of power that he's grabbed he's not
going to give that up
without a fight
and
nobody's going to come in and fix it by
themselves you know what i mean that
people are going to have to work
together in order for that to happen
all right i used the word goosebump a
few minutes ago and i don't want to
repeat myself but i have to because
drummer sends out a message on a
wideband channel
and carriage's delivery is
simply exquisite she goes this is kamina
drummer and this message is for the
traitor the coward marcolinaros
you hunted me a mine and still we are
here
i'm bent unbroken and bowed
and you
you're nothing
obviously i can't do justice to that
quote but
let's just um get your thoughts on it
please
yeah this is
i i liked how this came from her
watching
as you know they put this sleeve of
regrowth
gel on
joseph
he's still in a lot of pain michio is
there for him for you know as a hus as
as his
as his wife as his crewmate as his you
know
nurse i guess or doctor whatever role
that is that she's taking on their medic
and
she takes this and she goes out and
she's like you know what i'm tired of
this marco
it's this is the belt this is us this is
who we are it's we're not that we're not
what marco's doing leaving people behind
taking their taking their supplies and
hiding them out in space
to save for later just in case they're
needed
people are suffering right now i'm gonna
do something about it and
i'm not gonna do that quietly either you
know i'm gonna make sure that i call him
out
you know it's important that she decided
to do this wide beam so that everybody
everybody hears it right
and
she knows that's going to get back to
him
he knows that it's going to put her
family
in this and
they already have a they already have
you know there's already
people looking for them there's bounties
that they can collect
now she's just making it personal you
know what i mean so that is definitely
something you love to see
exactly and this is where i wanted to
mention the video game as well because
we are going to play as uh drummer in
this upcoming video game made by
telltale games and
they make uh narrative driven games
where you have to make
tough choices and those choices
sometimes affect how the story goes
so it's going to be more like a tv show
and maybe a spin-off of
uh the expense i'm not i'm not sure
about the time frame
uh so playing as drummer is just going
to be awesome like kergi is i think uh
still voicing this character
so
keep your eyes peeled for that one guys
yeah that was the impression i got that
she would be voicing the character and
that you would i think that i'm not
familiar you know i'm not familiar with
a lot of gaming stuff but
i've heard a lot of different people
talking about this and it's got got me
pretty excited to check it out
yeah we should also mention that drummer
and company take the containers with
them
so do you think this is going to solve
the belt's
supply problem for a little while at
least
yeah i mean i think that they i'd
um well they did say if in the episode
description of the next episode which i
covered in the last video i made and put
out
a few hours ago
that i mean it's not hard to put those
two things together right yeah that
series needs some humanitarian aid and
drummer
found herself with a large cache of the
pirate booty here that
might solve that problem
yeah
it's not vandalism she she didn't she
didn't do this just to
strike him by you know destroying some
of his
his stuff you know what i mean she
she went there with the purpose of
taking it from him
this is theft and redistribution so
yeah she's definitely going to be on
series in the next episode we saw that
in the teaser so she'll be bringing that
along with her for sure
alright anything to add here or
i just um
just want to point out the one more
walker line here so much for anonymity
yeah
and it's and it's kind of funny because
you know he was he he got pulled into
this because of his love of being a
pirate that's that was my take on his
character is that what you got as well
uh can you repeat this
he got pulled into this situation
because she
she she appealed to his love of being a
pirate like he
he wasn't political he he didn't he had
personal grievances with marco anaros
but
he was working for the free navy and she
was able to bring him over to her side
because
hey we might be able to steal stuff you
know what i mean
yeah
yeah drama definitely played him there
and he wanted to you know he wanted to
do this he does he doesn't want to have
his face out there but
it's kind of awesome here where you see
that
they pulled off this big thing they got
out of it i mean joseph lost an arm but
they still
were able to pull it off and
he also gets outed but you know so much
for anonymity we're gonna do this thing
we might as well do it right yeah he was
just supposed to deliver metrio to a
station and this is where he is now
that's pretty funny
yeah it is pretty funny
all right i think we can move on to the
zenobia
monica's latest video is quite impactful
as we see the belter holding the cat
saying how tired he is of all the
fighting he doesn't think there's a
difference between the inners and the
belters
because he says it's the people who want
more hate and the ones that just want to
live
so monica
flipped the script here because she was
supposed to make earthers look human
that was her that was her objective be
given to her by uh azerallah
and she really she realized that the
opposite would have to be established to
achieve that goal this can't be a
one-way street
so what did you think about this uh this
scene and what monica
did yeah i i i like the way that she
pivoted and i think you it's pretty
you know it was pretty telegraphed that
she was going to try to put her own
her own spin on what she was asked to do
she said i don't make propaganda and
it's kind of weird i mean
monica was a character that i thought
came off pretty shady when she was first
introduced you know she was trying to
sneak around the rossi and get
information from you know she was trying
to
shape that story in the way that was
kind of
kind of sensationalize it a little bit
so
this in this case you expect her to do
her own thing and
i think that
it points out that
abisarala is saying hey these these
belters these people over there they
need to look at us as human
and it's a thing that she's not capable
of doing like she's not able to return
that she's not able to see them as human
even though she says the right things
and she
has evolved as a character over the over
the seasons
there's still a divide in her head that
these people aren't going to be capable
you know these people them they're not
going to be able to to see us as humans
they're not going to be able to meet us
where we are
it might be that boot that you put on
their neck you know what i mean
this is also
go ahead peter you you're finished
i'm just saying this that you know it's
she has a glaring
there's a glaring thing there that she
can't see so i like how monica doing
this
it really it really it really serves
that role and you have to love that the
cat is named lucky earther because
that's the stereotype that everybody has
on people on earth and we also
i think we identify the most with the
earthers you know as
as far as who we would be if we were in
the story
and you know
that's the stereotype that they're given
everything and it's so easy to be an
earther you have all that free air
but think about some of the characters
that we know that came from earth think
about baltimore think about amos
you know it goes both ways
yeah exactly
yeah just because just because you live
on earth doesn't mean
you don't have any struggles
yeah that's something to keep in mind
and this reminded me of um
you know this difference between the
belters and earth is reminding me of
delgado's joke from season five do you
remember that
oh yeah
you know
these stereotypes are you know
they have been long established and
avasarala agrees that now thinks that it
it's not going to change
belters will
you know never see the earthers
from a sympathetic eye
and monica thinks the opposite won't
happen either so
this situation is not going to be
resolved by just a few propaganda movies
but you still love the effort you still
love to see it in action here because
she did a great job this is absolutely
yeah definitely pulls on the
heartstrings and makes you
feel something for these
people and of course the explosions go
off the attack happens at that time and
we see them jump in and they're
helping each other everybody is
on the same side in the in the heat of
the crisis
and i just wanted to
talk about this
super chat here really quick
ian fitzpatrick thank you for the ten
dollars
he he's talking about the nuke again
do any of you have suspicions that
philip or anyone on the pelo berk will
recover data supporting that holden
deactivated the nuke
what effects might this have on pella or
rossi crew
huh i think that
what we're going to talk about this
in a second
and and i'll get into it a little bit
more but
i think that
the idea that it was disarmed
it's it's and it's an absurd
it would be it's the thing about it is
it it's absurd to think that someone
would do that in an active battle
doesn't believe that happened
he thinks it was a mistake yeah
yeah i i mean the
the pella was trying to kill the ross
and ante
actively trying to to just to
erase them
so
when you have the chance to fight back
and and take out your opponent it almost
it's almost something that you can't you
can't process you're like why would
anyone do that and
you leave it there
that's the natural progression of that
thought is
no one would
why would anyone do that no one would
that's it that you don't really need to
think about it too much more but
philip isn't in a totally different
situation because
when he was trying to kill the ross ante
he knew he was going to be responsible
for killing his mother
so i think naturally he's going to think
that it was her that that deactivated it
even if they never just you know never
fight find out that's going to be his
head cannon for the the thing is that
his mom didn't want him to die that way
what do you think about that
yeah definitely and uh we'll get to his
um speech to hype up
the the crew members
so i think he was trying to hype himself
up there and convince himself
because uh
he realized that somebody on the
somebody on the rossi probably
his mother
saved them so
he feels guilty for that i think and
i will get to that like i said
i think uh we should probably talk about
marco and rosenfeld first before we get
to that part yeah definitely let's do
that
we have a great conversation between
marco and rosenfeld toward the end of
the episode as she informs informs him
that nobody was spaced as punishment
so marco's orders weren't followed
that's tough well she's i need i'll
interject there the the
the the two the true crew remember the
two highest ranking crew members on the
granicus were spaced or on the loud but
were spaced
they executed those two
what he did was he
yeah what he did was he gave that order
and then he said when you tell the guy
who is the captain of the granicus to do
this
if he comes to you and asks you to talk
to me and ask for mercy
then i want him spaced as well
so
she so she delivered this order that
these two people after you know he's
there with them whenever she's giving it
to him
they can't hear but but
they're working together to get the ship
in order
and he's going to throw them out of it
before he leaves that's that's the order
that he's given
so
marco anticipates that he's not going to
want to do that because
you know
it's it's murder
so
he tells her that if if she if he calls
her and asks her to
talk to him and change the order
then
he wants him
and he wants him and he does do that he
calls her and
she decides not to space him and that's
where she makes the stand with marco
well i see i i completely misread that
situation because i thought
the first two guys on um
was it on lauber
i thought they weren't spaced either so
uh sorry i administrated that situation
um but still uh the other guy rosenfeld
doesn't want to doesn't want him spaced
and
marco wonders what makes her think she
can talk to him this way
she argues that somebody has to
marco appreciates her blunt nature and
asks what she expects in
in victory if they win
and she is uh she wants girl she wants
the governorship of medina and once
again michael's like this gal is
ambitious
so they share a drink together as they
are in agreement now
rosenfeld is a new character but she's
already earned marco's trust i think
that that has gone over a little bit
too quickly for my liking
yeah i was just i was just thinking the
exact same thing because
some the other question earlier brought
up st drani and i think this is
i think that we understand what's
happening with this character
but i don't think they really
did a great job of establishing why
she's in the room in the first place
yeah i think they had to you know for i
think she's the exo right
second in command
maybe
uh
so yeah
an important character like this had to
be developed a little bit more so
you know maybe her backstory
you know how she came here
why she's on the pella
being um
marco's
secondhand marco is a right-hand woman
yeah i'm up two minds about it because i
i thought that in when i when i first
watched the season i thought that i
thought wow people are really going to
point out that they that who is this
person why is this person here
the if you read the books you know that
she came from the voltaire collective
the character is a little bit different
but
you know they they had their own
they had their own faction their own
power within
to bargain with the free navy the free
navy needed them just like the free navy
needed
sandrani's
people that it was
that's a little bit different too but
that was anderson dawes dawes's people
just like you know when fred johnson was
trying to do business he needed black
sky and he needed anderson dawes
there's all these different it's made up
of a bunch of different factions that
part's established and
that's where she comes from she comes
from one of those
it's just one that hasn't really
featured in the tv series until now
and here here she is she's standing
in and we're supposed to understand that
she's earned her way into the into the
room
that part is the part that's hard to
i think that they could have done better
but i think they're doing really good
with the character though is that
we can see how she is making herself
essential
and how she's noticing
the deficits in what marco has as far as
being able to
actually pull this thing off and she's
rising to the occasion of making that
you know trying to make him
trying to keep him from crashing and
burning do you agree with that part of
it absolutely i mean
we've been talking about you know over
the course of these two weeks since we
started covering uh
as we started doing these live streams
we've been talking about how marco has
been acting
emotionally at some at certain points
and
he definitely needs someone like
rosenfeld so her
introduction is great in that sense and
i think the actor is doing a fine job as
well
i do like the character but they
definitely should have
built her up a little bit more before
before
she she got here
yeah and i think if you go back and
re-watch and you really pay attention to
the dialogue in the in the introduction
scenes and stuff it's
it's technically there
i think she she you know all the
information you need is there but it's
just not as readily as a you know it's
just not readily apparent in the way
that it probably would have been if it
was eight episodes or
they were our each one was an hour long
or however you want to make the thing
structure it so there's more time and a
little bit more room to breathe in some
of these things you know
yeah
also just right now i'm thinking you
know if
if roosevelt if rosenfeld thinks you
know
they can't win this war and uh marco you
know if this is if she thinks this is a
lost cause
i'm thinking would she sell uh del marco
out
or uh
in exchange for immunity maybe i mean i
don't know if that's the thing but i'm i
i'm thinking maybe that's why this is
heading rosenfeld betraying marco
i'm not sure though
just possibility
i guess that is one thing you pick up on
the charac yes that is
one thing you pick up on the character
as they're they are
they're fast thinking and resourceful so
i don't think that's i don't think
that's a strange
thing to to speculate about
but like you said you don't really know
if that's even a possibility at this
point
yeah for example this commenter says
says i think she's loyal to the cause
she'll die with him so
people think about you know think about
her differently i guess
uh well
i think it's just open for
interpretation because it's not really
we don't really know you know that she's
she's new she's uh
she's
she's not we don't know for sure what's
going on
we know that here it's made
explicit what she wants right she wants
to be
the the governor of the most important
felter held
station
probably the most important thing yeah
probably the most important thing in the
entire
solar system so we know what her
motivation in that sense is
but but we're just learning
episode by episode what she's all about
okay i think we can move on to tadeo and
philip they're eating in the mess
when drummer's message is going out and
everybody is watching it
phillip attempts to rally the troops
here with a speech about how drummer is
the enemy and this is war he knows that
it's kill or be killed
he has no other option and neither do
all of these uh crew crewmen and crew
women he's trying to convince himself
more than anybody else to be honest
uh
especially you know when you see him
walk away and
he has that weird look on his face
you kind of sense that
you know this was a this was almost a
speech he gave to himself did you get
the same impression
yeah that was my take on it and at first
i think they did a pretty good job and i
think the actor did a pretty good job of
putting that there to be discovered he
you could see him shift he's he's really
trying to
he's really trying to get the idea out
of his head
first first and foremost that he just
got that his mother might have been
behind
deactivating the nuke
that we were just talking about that he
gets that information first and you see
that the wheels are turning he's
thinking about that
then we get
drummer coming on and calling his father
a clown basically
you know
and
making him look terrible
calling him out and he can't immediately
strike back at her so that that that's
that's when you when someone talks about
your dad that way it's not really
easy to process either
and that makes me think you know
how do how do kids of famous people
deal with you know reading comments
about their parents all the time
that must be insane i mean
i'm kind of going off the tangent here
but
that must be so
so yeah he's got a lot of stuff going on
plus his dad has him down working on
like entry-level position at the company
you know he totally demoted him down to
the new to the mail room basically is
this succession now
yeah and so here he is he's he's got all
this stuff going on and then he hears
todayos say that at least it wasn't the
inners that hit the supply depot
and then
he tries to do he tries to he tries to
to
meet the situation
and i think it's pretty obvious that his
heart isn't isn't a hundred percent in
it
he's not really you know and you see he
he watches facial expressions he's
trying but it's not
it's not natural anymore he has to force
it
and he's trying to say
of course this is right of course i
believe this
of course you know and like you said
he's trying to
trying to convince himself as much as
anybody else
yeah and i'm not sure if we're going to
get more of tadio but
i really liked him if this was just a
you know this is just a one-episode
appearance
i'm glad they introduced them
i think there were there were several
references to his brother and i thought
that that stood out to me a lot the
first time
the way that he cared about his brother
the way that they had sort of that hard
luck story where
his brother was still a young young man
or a kid at the time and he had to take
him in because something happened to his
parents
so i think that connection is something
that
that's really front and center with that
character
and it's hilarious because
he's i we didn't mention it before i
just wanted to come back to it it's
hilarious because he is
he's like
nobody i mean he has a little bit of uh
he's above some people on the ship
because he's you know that's who philip
goes to
but he gets he gets the son of the of
the of the entire thing that he has to
work with at that point i thought that
was hilarious the first time i watched
it because he's like talking
he doesn't know who's there and he's
like complaining that he's like oh hey
it's you
yeah it's like
you know i mean you can't tell you can't
tell philip what to do really but that's
your job all of a sudden you know
and then rosenfeld comes in as well and
yeah daddy doesn't know if you know
philip sees philip's gonna go away or
gonna continue to work with him
yeah the situation they put him in was
pretty funny
yeah so
the philip whenever i made the post
yesterday asking what other people
wanted to talk about
besides drummer and i think we should
probably talk about drummer a lot more
as well
but the idea of philip comes up and it's
difficult for me because i read the
books long before
the series came out so i always knew
where the
where i thought the philip character
would end up
it's kind of hard to to discuss him
with that information already in my head
what are
what do you i guess i'll ask you you can
be the stand-in for the viewers and then
they can actually
just tell us in the comments we can do a
little q and a kind of thing but
what would you like to see it the thing
about the thing about phillips character
and marco as well and i mentioned this
before so i won't go too far into it but
as characters they've always been a
little bit difficult for me when reading
because
they're just an extension of naomi's
story
they they have lives they have inner we
see there's point of view characters
they have we get their their inner
thoughts and how they see the world and
everything else
but they wouldn't exist if it wasn't for
naomi and her position with the ross and
ante does that make sense
yeah no i
i understand how it's it's a packet it's
a package
they all they're it's a family unit kind
of thing where they don't exist if it
isn't for naomi so it's hard not to
for me at least and i'm not saying this
in a bad way i'm just saying that to
talk about them as individuals is a
little bit difficult
because
of course they're the way that they are
because that
is how
it works how that's how it fits into the
bigger picture as far as how naomi
became who she was
it's sort of like holden and his family
like
his parents the way that they the way
that he was conceived and the way that
they lived on earth before he ran away
and joined the navy it's not so
important other than
it's a part of who he who he is and
that's a part of how
he deals with the other people in his
life as a result
and so
with philip
it's an
he's a child soldier and that's terrible
and
he does a lot of
a lot of really unforgivable stuff in
that process which like you said earlier
it's tragic right he is
there's not really a happy ending
baked into that there can't be in a lot
of ways
but i guess so
all of that is to say what would you
like to see happen for this character at
this point
honestly i can't i can't see any other
way than to
have philip
uh save
save the rossi in you know
as basically a
as basic to basically return the favor
because
they purposefully made him aware
that the missile might have been
uh disarmed by someone on the rossi
he thinks it's you know
uh tada mentions it's holden but
philip doesn't know what to believe
maybe it was his mother
so i think that that's in the back of
his mind right now because
they want to sit set it up so that
he has a reason to save naomi when push
comes to shove
and i think
this will bring probably bring about
marco's downfall
marquez put philip through all of this
you know that that's the reason he's a
child soldier
and you know
philip thought about how different his
life might have been
if you feel if marco wasn't his father
this episode
so i think there's a reason for that
and all of all of this all of this
thought process is going i think it's
going to lead to philly betraying marco
and that's what i think i mean i mean
logically that makes sense and
i think that is
i think that's a good way to
i mean i guess that means that the
character is working out how he should
because
it's very hard to imagine him doing that
it's very hard to imagine what what that
would
what his life would look like if he
wasn't the son of marco inaros
i guess you know
there might be a way out of this where
you know
maybe he doesn't have to sacrifice
himself per se maybe
he still betrays marco but
he's able to get out because you know he
he
he gives marco he gives marco up maybe
that's what's going to happen
yeah and as as
as as this is this comment here was
pointing out
philip is one of the main point of view
characters in book six in babylon's
ashes
so you you watch this
transformation happen through his
internal his internal thoughts his his
monologue so her
his you know his thought processes right
there
do you think that in the show they're
doing a good job of
keeping it a little bit mysterious or
are people enjoying this character do
you like this character
i do but
i think people are you know 70 percent
liking it 30 percent not liking it
that's the impression i get
uh at this point
not sure why people wouldn't like philip
because
yeah i think he's a great character
like we said before the actor looks
exactly like how i would imagine uh
naomi and marco's son
yeah
and
his story is interesting because you
know it's as basic as it gets
he's got a terrible father
his mother had to run away from his
from run away from his father so
all he had
growing up was his father and
that has shaped his future and
meeting naomi then you know complicated
things and then he she had to leave
again so
you know
he
he went back to square one
without his mother
and then you know we had the conflict
between him and marco this season
where
marco
blamed him so he feels let down once
again
you know it kind of repeats itself this
story but it definitely makes sense and
i've liked it so far
i can't really come
i can't really talk to you know if it
would if it was better
in the books because of because it was
uh from his point of view
but i think they're they're making
they're doing a good job
you know depicting his inner struggle
yes just from a show perspective
i think what's difficult about the
character is that you know he's
responsible for the atrocities
maybe
it's mostly his father but he was there
he took an active role
and it makes it complicated to actually
like you feel sorry for him but
it's it's not easy it's sort of like a
jamie lannister
situation in
song of ice and fire
his character starts out by throwing a
kid
out out off the uh
you know
trying to cover up what he's doing with
his sister he throws a kid
out of a tower and
cripples him for life you know what i
mean everything he does after that is
still defined by that
yeah that's always at the back of your
mind
and i think you know what philip did
wasn't
i think i guess wasn't as drastic as
that but
he played a role in the rocks
destroying earth
yeah didn't he didn't he um
didn't he attack a a u.n ship when he
when we first saw him
a u.n research ship who who was you know
tracking the asteroids
i think that's that's how we were
introduced yeah
and he killed he killed people there and
or maybe his people killed people but he
left his his crew crewmate behind too
because there was a ticking clock
situation
and sin was saying we got to go back we
got to try and he was like no the
mission needs to happen that's true
he was sort of presented as a you know
calculated and
you know motivated
competent
you know it's it was
he's a child soldier but he the soldier
part is real that's what i think you
know you're supposed to take away from
that
yeah and at some point when
you know when your mother
comes to you know change your
perspective and
you don't do that i guess then
there's no one to blame but yourself
at this current moment
so i just want to acknowledge sam jovi
the two dollar
super chat thank you for that
thank you sam jones
he's quoting uh diogo there i believe
right
and then we have another one from eos
seidman
five dollars thank you for that
it is very worthwhile to read the books
everyone it would be fun to discuss with
you all here
if pete has time to do book reviews
yeah i i also i endorse this idea that
everyone should read the books i do plan
on
doing something book related once the
show
is concluded i think there'll be more
interest in what happens after
because
you know not everybody
right now everyone is sort of focused on
where we're at and
once it ends it's gonna be like wait a
minute what happens after this and
i i think that
the books are
they're a really good companion
to even if you've already seen the show
it's a really good companion
to get a little bit more and
the the
i guess where where i have
where
what what's difficult about the books
and what it has been for
a while since it moved past the show as
far as it has
is that
season six book six it feels like it's
so long ago from the book reading
perspective
like it's almost like you're going back
and looking at something historical like
this is a thing that happened the war
with the free navy is a thing that
happened
back in the old days
does that make sense do you understand
what i'm saying there yeah yeah
absolutely
and it's weird it's weird
i can't imagine how you felt about a
foundation then
yeah well i mean foundation
the story the narrative jumps forward in
time hundreds of years
but
well i guess what i'm talking about here
is more like the
the mindset of
when you think of all the character like
whenever i whenever i came to do season
five and season six i sort of had to
go back and
and sort of
re-immerse myself in that part of the
story and try not to think about what
happens after because like i said in
this season whenever bobby comes to the
to the ship
it feels like yeah that's bobby she is
you know everybody knows bobby bobby and
because in the later books she plays
such a large role that
you sort of have to go back in time with
your thinking to say hey these these
people don't really know bobby they're
just getting to this is like her first
time really being on the ship
so there's a ton of stuff that's like
that in the book so it's it's i i
i want to just focus on season six until
that's done and then
i definitely just finished you know the
ninth book i read that a couple days
after it came out i definitely want to
talk about that stuff
but i'd rather do it in a way where i'm
just focusing on that part of the story
instead of jumping back and forth
but definitely thank you for that
definitely thank you for the
suggestion and i agree that people
should read the books
and we'll see if we can't put something
together after the season wraps up
i definitely think i will do a laconia
book related video
but maybe before the end of the season
or at or
to come up you know in
with the end of the season
so we'll we'll see about that in the
next couple weeks
is this another one here too yeah okay
all right justin merritt thank you for
the ten dollars serious question
especially for book readers
the books and show never really got me
to sympathize with belter fanaticism
they seem like whiners
disgust p.s no belter is as likable as
jamie lannister
sorry to completely disagree with you
but
i brought up jamie lannister because
he's kind of a pet peeve character to me
like i really like his i really like the
way that he's written in the books but
i'll never forgive him for throwing bran
bran was always my favorite character in
the in the early books so i would i
never have been able to to forgive him
for throwing bran out the window
i mean he's a spoiled
spoiled rich kid with his banging his
sister and
i mean you can stop there
you understand yeah it's enough isn't it
it's enough but um
i get it i mean it's it's
it's it's a there's a there's a class
distinction
these
the their
the fanaticism
i mean that's never really cool no
matter who's doing it but i i never
really
i never really i always i i think i was
pretty sympathetic to the belters
at least in the books
early on
i think they did a pretty good job of
setting up the idea that these people
are getting
exploited
and that it you're not supposed it's you
know it's there's a there's the whole
colonialism and
that's all
pretty plain it's not it's not
it's not a big secret you know what i
mean it's
you see that
there's these different gold rushes that
happen in seoul system when they first
start to go to the rocks and they start
to mine and
it's just like the ones in our own
history the people who went to try to
get rich in the gold fields
the people
didn't it was the people who sold them
the shovels right
that's that's the
the you know the people who had the
who who ran the brothels and who
sold them booze every night whenever
they came back from from working and you
know
trying to make their way
this is the same situation and it's a
little bit more extreme in that
these people have been
they've
they've become
different physically different
from
people on earth you can notice them
right away and the show doesn't really
come off that the in the show you just
see them as
having
tattoos and talking with this different
uh you know different
kind of creole that they use but
they they're
i think that it's you know
i think that they're supposed to be
sympathetic and i i
i don't know what do you think about
that
i struggle with this you know i i kind
of thought like justin a little bit when
i started watching the show especially
you know season one season two but as i
got to know
as i learned more about
you know this whole
just so as i learned about this whole
story the soul system
how
the belters were i suppose exploited and
you know you have to think you know
let's just say you were born on a belter
station
and you know nothing about earth
you're just born there
and you're raised a certain way
your thought you're exploited and you
are
so
why would you why would you
i suppose why would you not hate the
earthers or the inners you know i think
that
it's natural for everybody on the belt
to hate them
even if
even if the exploitation wasn't as bad
as as bad as it is
this the situation they're in already i
think is enough to hate the inners
that's the feeling i have at this moment
yeah and i think that um
i think that
i think that early on i think that's why
it's uh why miller is such an effective
character because
he is a self-hating belter
he walks around in a hat that he looks
like he tries to make himself look like
an earther
he tries to work for an earther
corporation
you know he he's a traitor to his people
as as it was pointed out in that first
episode
where
you kind of you kind of understand by
seeing him and his situation
why it's not that surprising that some
people are more radical about their
their
situation
yeah and you know these things happen
just don't happen in a single instance
you know they take
decades and different
people to you know
you know
they don't suddenly get the free navy
they don't suddenly get marco
it gets progress progressively more
fanatic so you got to look at look at it
that way
it's generational for sure and i think a
good story that's really short is
butcher of anderson station which they
did show
in episode five of the first season if i
remember correctly but
if you read that if you read that story
it's it's it gives you more perspective
on that because of the fact that
fred johnson is an earther who is
put in you know we know him as the face
of the
the nice opa
or whatever you want to call his faction
and
their introduction anderson dawes and
his introduction is
is
fantastic it's it's really short and
they they cover it really fast but it
gives you that impression of like why
you should care about the belters
we got another we got another inquiring
minds want to know
thank you for the five dollars again
would you jump through the ring gate why
or why not
great question
i think this depends on important
questions i think i think it's an
important question
i think this depends on
i this depends on you know where you
live
on the expanse universe if i'm a nurse
there and my situation is good and if
i'm wealthy i'm not going anywhere
if i'm on mars and
you know i'm thinking this mars
situation this mars experiment isn't
going too well
i'm joining
i'm joining the breakaway fleet for sure
and if i'm if i'm on the belt
count me in
if there's even a one percent chance of
finding and finding a habitable planet
i'm going in
yeah i i would go through i mean i've
i've always had wonderlust so i think if
i was alive in the universe then i would
definitely
have already gone through the ring
first chance i would be
on a generation or a colony ship and
ready to
find myself completely
disappointed with how difficult and
awful these planets are
i think you know i think i think it's a
great idea i mean just to see this place
for the first time uh one of my favorite
things from
a different show for all mankind was
whenever
gordo was on the on the moon and he was
just walking around talking to himself
saying i'm the first person that ever
saw this you know
i totally could relate to that idea and
so yeah i would be through the ring
gates i think that is for sure
but i think also whenever you got there
and you realize you can't eat any of any
of the food you can't you got to be
careful everything is basically poison
and
it takes
months and months to get anything that
you need brought into your community
that
it would probably have a different feel
at that point
a comment who said you know if you're a
belter you can't
live on a planet
i guess that makes sense right but
couldn't you find
could you find a planet that would suit
your body
with it with its gravity gravity
well they don't really ever that's i
mean the point of it is that
and i guess we saw this through naomi
some people just can't make the
transition there's a certain percentage
when they arrived on illus
i think it was maybe 30 percent of the
people
had to stay on the ship forever in orbit
you know what i mean so
i think you missed this one piece that's
why i brought it up it was earlier
yeah i wanted to come back to this one
swing man 20 thank you it's interesting
earthers have no opportunity in billions
of people
martians live under the threat of
annihilation from earth
and belters above all else need food
water to survive but they have
access to opportunity
yeah nobody oh and i think we touched on
this a little bit in the when we were
talking about lucky arthur
the
nobody
nobody's doing great here except for the
people that are doing great and it
doesn't really matter where they're from
the the capital class are are
are still
the ones that are
benefiting from everybody else and
these people
i mean on earth
i i one of the things i've always liked
this about the books in the way that
they
they kind of play off that like whenever
bobby first comes to earth and she gets
that
she gets that idea
of everyone being
lazy and fat and getting everything for
free i mean being on basic isn't nice
it's not something you want it's not
something that is just like okay you
have this and you can do whatever you
want
you don't even actually have access to
currency or anything you just get what
you need to survive
which is
not ideal but it's the opposite of what
they have in in the belt right in the
belt they just want to make sure that
they have those things they don't they
just want to make sure they have air and
water
because they're gonna die if they don't
get it
so
it's a pretty nice parallel and when you
look at the different people and as you
know martians they
they kind of have that idea hey you know
we all work together and we're all in
for the the greater good and we're gonna
do this thing
but they don't have a lot of
they don't have a lot of you know
individuality either so
it's
i think it does a pretty good job of
playing those different things against
each other and
having the characters realize that and
have to question that themselves and you
do you think so i mean is that something
you get from
i absolutely agree and because you know
this is not a foreign concept you know
we don't have to think about uh
fictional
fictional um
pieces of ours you know this
we have a we have a um
we have this situation on earth because
you know
people on some continents can't even
find food or water
while
people on more affluent
affluent countries
they have what they need to survive but
they can't find happiness and
i i suppose
it depends on it depends on what you
want from what you what you want from
life
if you just have to if you just want to
survive because you don't have any basic
supplies
that's what's that's what um that's what
you will
aim to get
and that's what belters want to get and
if you if you're an earther
yeah you have everything and not
everything you need but you're basically
able to survive at least you have food
and water
but
what is the point of life
what are you doing here well
you know that that feeling i think must
be
incredibly daunting because
can you even imagine you know
why would you why would you go on i mean
in that situation why would you go on
what's what's the point i i guess
i guess um
the only thing keeping you going is your
your um instinct to survive
that that's all
yeah and i think that's what makes
belter so compelling isn't it it's that
that
you think
that is i mean that is the ultimate if
you can't
knowing that you don't have enough water
in x amount of time and then knowing
there's nothing you can do about it
it's frightening
indeed
and i think this is i think this is
where i kind of wanted to
circle back around to
duarte because
that's one of the things we get from
we don't really get it laid out but we
don't get it completely defined but you
can see that he is
taking that and he's saying well i have
a different spin on it
all together
he's talking about losing that dream of
the dream of mars and how he thought
that would be there forever
that was the ex's existential crisis for
martians right that they had been
keeping themselves going they've been
they've been sustaining themselves with
this dream that
future generations would be able to have
that same
free air that they have on earth that
those lucky earthers those lazy bastards
that they can
just
have that gravity and air and they can
just walk around outside and jump in the
ocean
and it's all taken away from them
and
he has it you know it's easy for him to
and
it's easy for him to say look it's
because of
it's not because of anything else it's
because of that old government on mars
these people
they just weren't hardcore enough we
need to be just a little bit more
hardcore and stick to these core
principles
and we're going to be able to
create the greatest society that
has ever existed
you know that makes me think
this dratha fella is gonna he's gonna
turn out pretty well then
because he has learned from he's pr he's
learned from uh
he's learned from his um ancestors
mistakes
am i getting that correctly
yeah you're you're spot on there
yeah i mean
he definitely sets off some red flags
doesn't he
yeah
now
the most scary thing about him is you
know he knows
he it looks like to
it looks like he knows what he's talking
about and what he wants
and you know that's the scary thing
because
if
if a bad person has an obj has an
objective in mind a clear objective and
he has a road map
and you know he has the means of course
to
enact that plan that is pretty scary
so uh i'm i'm really wondering where
that's gonna go but that's the that's
the sad thing we're not gonna see this
on a tv show at least for a while
yeah and it it takes time for something
like that i mean they're in in strange
dogs they just wrote they just arrived
on the planet
there is no time for anything to develop
yet there hasn't been any time for
anything to develop
yet just want to uh
change gears for a second to thank you
pierce webber for the 499 super chat
this one they don't have a question this
one to say thanks and they give you a
little shout out there benja for your
yellowstone videos
and thank you pierce
uh i expect to see you on my 1883 videos
as well
then that show just started as well
i think you know we mentioned a
different tv show here so i wanted to
bring up this comment as well david
lincoln says what is your favorite tv
show besides this
mine is yellowjackets i think he's
talking about recent shows
do you have anything in mind i'm i'm all
in on station 11. that's the only thing
that that's really caught my
attention i haven't given i haven't seen
yellow jackets though i've heard good
things but
i was
i i wasn't aware of it when it first
came out and then it became a situation
where there was already
a handful of episodes so i just haven't
been able to each week it gets harder to
jump in because i know i'll be watching
like five or six or seven
eight you know what i mean yeah just let
it down and do it
yeah i definitely want to check it out
i've been doing dexter the that's the
other show i've been doing so a lot of
people have been bringing that up on
those videos that they'd like to see
something but
yeah i haven't had a lot of time
to really watch just for fun lately but
i've been really enjoying
station 11.
the show i'm watching for fun at the
moment is
that i'm not covering is a show called
travelers i think it's available on
netflix
i'm not sure if if it is that way in
every single country but
i wasn't expecting a lot from that show
but
i like the way they um
it feels like they all have you know the
standalone episode like procedurals
it feels that way but they also have
multi-episode arcs
and they also have season-long arcs and
they also have multi-season arc so the
way they mixed all of those story mix
all of those stories together is quite
interesting it's about a time traveler
so
you know
that's a good start right there so you
might want to check that out
i haven't finished it yet that's the
first i'm hearing of it honestly i don't
think i heard anybody else mention that
yeah i think it was cancelled because
you know the name is
incredibly generic travelers and what a
name
but yeah that's what i've been watching
in 1883 like i said that's
that just started i think that's a good
show semelius in it
yeah i feel wrong with sam elliott
uh what did you say sorry i said you
can't go wrong with sam yeah we had that
conversation and off off stream before
absolutely yes
and in general i think
i don't want to i don't want to go on
for too long but in general
dark is one of my favorite shows
another one is me too obviously and
another one is bosch
the last season was a little bit
disappointing but that's easily the best
cop show ever
and in terms of comedy
oh yeah you should i'm about it's too
long i think you might not have time
but yeah that's it i don't want to go on
for too long
yeah bosh they they dropped screeners in
my in my account and i was look looking
at it said season seven i said
definitely not starting that
maybe
60 plus hours to get caught up with that
yeah maybe when you retire
the swing man says that you should
definitely check out our kane thanks
again for the two dollars i've heard a
lot of good things but i i haven't i
haven't um
i'm kind of biased because
it's about league of legends a video
game that
i hate
i mean not because it's a bad video game
but
i don't like that style so
i don't think i'll watch it
i agree with i agree with sabco bds that
dark is definitely the best netflix
original
absolutely
their new show will be out this year
1899.
well that yeah that might be quite
interesting as well not to be confused
with
1889 which is the show you're covering
right now yeah that
you know
the 1899 1899 guys might must be you
know thinking oh my goodness
why did they have to come out just for
every year for for for
tv shows with 1800
in the title
yeah
uh this one's good as well by the way
watch continuum if you like travelers i
watched it as episodes
weekly that would continue that's i
think a canadian show
uh that was pretty good as well
but what is this what is this what is
this right here what is this
it's not netflix original
no i'm not sure
i think
maybe it's
it's not a production you know
they haven't produced it maybe
okay
i just it seems like a weird
a weird comment
interesting it was definitely
it definitely came out on netflix so
yeah they're the distributor for sure
absolutely
i mean
uh
i'm just looking at
you know the production company
yeah it's it's why domenim burke
television i think that's what he's
talking about you know being really
pedantic
uh yeah but okay yeah but the
distributor is netflix
so let's think about oh there's another
one here let's see what this says
thank you again sam jovi two dollars on
apple tv see what jason mamoa had me
reeling
this is one i've never watched have you
seen this
no i i've heard good things about it but
my friends convinced
are trying to convince me to watch but i
haven't
i i've had i heard mixed results or
mixed reviews that's why i never really
picked it up because i heard that it was
it was a slow starter and
the premise didn't sound that
interesting but yeah some people seem to
really like it
maybe it would have been better
as a book i'm thinking
i haven't you know i haven't watched it
but the concept seems like it would be
better in a book
yeah um
let's try to i think we should try to
bring it back around to sure
to the expanse here
because
we could definitely
get way off the topic there and yeah
it's getting pretty late as well so i
think yeah we should give our finals we
do need to wrap it up so let's let's do
this if you're in the chat right now
thank you for supporting the channel
thank you for sticking around
let's
throw us off some
expanse season 6 episode 4 questions if
you have any and we'll try to get to a
couple more before we wrap this up
because
i get up super early in the morning to
do this ben just stays up super late at
night where he is and
i can feel that my energy is starting to
decline with every every minute that
passes from from here on out so let's
see what we can do as far as questions
and
what you want to talk about i mean
drummer is this was
this this episode was drummer wasn't it
i mean that was absolutely big takeaway
yeah i just wanted to you know after
watching this i just wanted to watch
your drummer video because
uh i didn't i didn't actually watch that
one but the one you did before before
the season kicked off i think
yeah i immediately thought you know i
should probably watch this now because
this episode was
awesome
you know we we could have made a
we could have made this stream all about
drummer it was that good
and you know i already talked about how
excited i am about
playing that character
in a video again
and you know
seeing her here you know flash fleshed
out even more
yeah
you know in season five as well you know
that that has been a really great
experience and
i think this is going to be her this is
going to be
how we remember her you know this speech
and
the
supply depot sequence
it's definitely going to stick with me
yeah i definitely don't want to jump
ahead i did make the
the teaser video about the upcoming
episode and and all that goes along with
that i don't want to get into that here
but um
but yeah i thought that this was i
thought that this
this like where she's at is
it all made a ton of sense and
it's just a great situation for
a character that
i mean the thing about the thing about
the thing about drummer here is that
she has respect among the belters
when she says something about marco
people are gonna take that to heart
but then there's still this situation of
like
the other side is
the inner planets
so she can't exactly just
she can't just exactly
team up with them you know what i mean
but
i i i thought that i mean the joseph
thing
it was it was shocking it was gruesome
i'm glad that they did it the way they
did it because that gave the chance to
for michio to come back in
and and and for her to be
an integral part of their family
i didn't think that that was i mean
do you think that it was a
did that feel like a big loss did joseph
losing his arm did that feel like it's i
mean for some of the other stuff that
kamina's already experienced in her
story
it's kind of he it kind of felt like a
side note to me or you know just sort of
a sort of like yeah okay well they can
you know amos had his hand shot off he
grew a new hand like
kind of like buck up dude you know
there's other stuff going on here
yeah since it's going to grow back
uh yeah in that sense
i guess uh her
her radio message here
was kind of over the top right
but um
i get it i mean
you know even the prospect of
even the prospect of losing joseph
might have affected
drummer
so maybe that's why she's reacting this
way oh you know that brings up i just
want to this is a little off topic but i
i i was really surprised when i watched
this season that they didn't bring
oksana back in any way
in these episodes did you
as you're watching these first episodes
were you looking for her did you did
that seem like unresolved
plot threat or what did you think about
that
right now i can't
uh oksana who is she
in the finale last season whenever oh
yeah yeah yeah her family split up half
of her family went away and it's like i
forgot yeah i forgot her name yeah
yeah for here we are four episodes in of
two thirds of the way through the season
and there's really not been any mention
of them i found that surprising
i think i didn't find it
i i guess i forgot about her completely
because
you know as as my reaction suggested
there
so i didn't really you know miss mr
didn't look out for her so
yeah i'm not too sure about that
because
i was curious because
some of the drama last season with her
kind of irritated me a little bit
and i was glad she was gone
i didn't you know i didn't look after
her
once this season started
yeah
i i see you pulled up this question
about marco's tattoos do you know do you
know the answer to that question no i
don't that's why i actually brought it
up i want to know too
i'm a little bit i did anyone sound off
on this in the in the comments this is
something that keon alexander has talked
about but i've never really paid close
attention to
so i think the answer is out there but i
don't actually
i've never really heard the way he
explains it
the way that i would
the way that i would think
the reason i would think that it's that
way is because marco wants to
present himself
in a way that is
he he has enough sense to know that if
he wants to
have real power he has to resemble real
power
i think it would be the way to to
describe that
so
in the books
well yeah he's a belter
through and through he came up as just
as as
as you know you would and then
i think he would he makes a conscious
decision to be able to
i know you get this from naomi's
chapters that
he he's learned to to present himself in
a way that isn't
offensive to people in the in the inner
planets
like when he gives a speech you don't
hear his you don't hear his belt her
accent as much as you would if you know
does that make sense that makes a lot of
sense yes
and skittles
asks
did
yeah didn't read the books
yet but uh duarte feels creepy am i
reading him wrong
from from a non-book reader perspective
i i have the same feeling
and i think
it can talk to this better talk about
this better
yeah i think we did talk about that in
the in the uh in the beginning when we
were talking about him and he is
he he is creepy that that going and
talking to an eight-year-old kid at her
brother's funeral
that way
i i feel like that's a conscious choice
by the writers to make you wonder what's
up with this guy
and some joey asks with another five
dollar super chat thank you sam charlie
since their chemistry in laconia is
different can they drink the water there
or so they have to stay away from the
aqua
i don't know if it's a serious question
or if they they just wanted to throw
that i think that reference out there
again
yeah i know
yeah water is the same everywhere that's
why it's necessary for life the
difference is that
as as the tree of life
establishes itself there's a lot of
different evolutionary
decisions
things that happen by circumstance that
make
chemistry
income battle income
incompatible across the different trees
of life that
have evolved
that was one of my favorite parts of
book four was all of the exo biology
stuff from lv
all right but you got to when she got to
ellis
do you have it do you have any questions
you want to answer peace
i'm trying to look at them here
i don't see anything that's jumping out
at me
and it's it's getting pretty late here
so yeah we're gonna have to wrap this up
and i want to thank everyone
that
came out
we're trying to
get a little better each
time next week
i think we'll go back
to
i think we'll go back to
a day earlier like we have monday night
yeah but i think
for the finale we might try to do it
right after that happens like that day
or the next day or something like that
uh we both i i have to get my recap put
together once the show comes out so
we'll have to see how that works but
i'm i'm definitely enjoying this format
i was a little bit
today i was definitely
sleep deprived so i hope that
it was still a fun time it was
worthwhile
we'll definitely be continuing to do
that so let us know in the comments
what you want to see in the future
do you have anything else you want to
plug anything
yeah sure thing uh you can check out my
channel banjo tv um
like i said i cover 1883 at the moment
uh billions is going to come back later
this month
there's also resident alien maybe i'll
cover pika blinders because season 6 is
coming out soon early 2022 from what i
understand so yeah i cover a lot of
crime dramas and some sci-fi i'll cover
the finale of the expanse for example
so definitely check out my channel and
thanks for reminding me again pete
these have been it's great
i've been dealing
i've been dealing with the laws of the
expanse better because because of these
streams
yeah i i whenever i do my my recap i try
to
i try to do that for across the spectrum
so that everyone can
can look at what happened and then you
know draw their own conclusions so it's
nice to be able to
talk about what my you know what what uh
what i'm really thinking about whenever
i'm watching some of these different
things because i think they're doing
some great character work this
this um
this year and then this season i think
that some of this stuff has been
fantastic to think about it kind of
sticks with you
in a way that
you know that is it's definitely it
definitely
is worth taking a second look at and
looking a little bit closer at how these
characters are are getting through this
situation so it's been a lot of fun i've
been happy that
i was happy that you were
interested in doing this with me and
that everybody's been coming out so i
think that's a great place to leave
things
thanks for watching guys we'll talk to
you next week